Sao nay, người ta hàng tâm năm 2018, công an tính điên bình đã thì hành các quy định hơi tố của an hình dự.
Hơi tố bị cánh và lệ mắt bị cánh để tâm giám đối với với vấn vấn vấn tuyền.
Bây giờ anh tên điên năng định, xin năm 2018, chú phần năng định tính điên.
Về tội, lợi giống các quyền tự gió dân chủ giống phạm lợi ít của nhà nước quyền, lợi ít hợi pháp của tổ chức cả nhân.
Từ năm 2018, người ta hàng điên năm 2018, mấy mấy vấn vấn tuyền đã có tâm tính an.
Tên sự về có tổ chụng các tài sản, cư dịch tàn trí đe chơi phép trích mà tủy, mô bàn trè phép trích mà tủy, tàn tríng vô phía thu sơ.
Với các tổ chân này, mấy mất thị tương cho thành an tại các trẻ dâm của bụng an và trẻ tâm dâm công an tính điên.
Trong đó, thử dân tại trẻ dâm đi khánh, bộ công an, là tương ngày 2018, một năm 2018, mấy mấy mấy mấy mấy mấy mấy mấy.
Sau khi trở về địa phương, thử dân đam tải các video clip và là chiến trên tài khoản phía s目 tế đến ó phía sô để kể về thời gian chấp hành án tại các trẻ dâm của bụng an, trẻ tạm dâm của công an tính điên.
Trong phía là chiến ngày 2018, có thời gian một dựa hai mấy phút bộ mấy hai dây, khi kể về những lấy chấp hành án tại trẻ dâm thì khánh với các lỗi dùng xuân tà.
Sài sự thật đã thú hút bà mấy bệnh nghiên trình trong lật xem hơn một gí lợt bình luật lợt lợt lại, thả tiêm và chiếc sẻ tiêm đến người mấy sáo tháng 12.
Qua chiến điều tra không cảnh rất hiện sự công an tính điên cũng đã làm việc với những tài nhân, đơn vị có lưu quan để kiểm tra,
sát thực tòan bộ sự việc và sát định những thông tin giòn những văn thị lán truyền về trẻ dâm ni khánh, bộ công an, là hoàn toàn về đặt và sài sự thật.
Đà sự phản xanh dự, quyết tính của cạnh bộ quân sáo, bán sám thi trẻ dâm ni khánh, bộ công an, người dưới đường xác hội tiêu cờ,
ai hưởng sau đến những an của cơ quan chức năm và những hưởng đến tình dình như anh in trật tự trình không dân mạc.
Mò dù đã được cơ quan chức năm dài thiết, hưởng giấn thực hiện quyền thiêu này, tốt cao theo đúng trình tự pháp lật.
Tình như người phản thư i vẫn khổ ý sự dùng hạng xác hội để lại chiến, phát tán nhiều tục tiên mang tính quyết kết, sinh tạng,
giúp phạc i tiến của cơ quan, tổ chức và cà nhân liên quan nhằm tủ hút sự chuyến, tạo rất lận tư cuộc chiến không dân mạc.
Tại cơ quan công an, hưởng em phát thư i đã thường nhận những phát ngôn trên mạng só hội về thời gian bị cân chấp hành án tại trẻ dâm ni khánh, bộ công an là thương tiên xin tạng không đúng sự thật.